Koalas have an organ
unlike anything else
in the animal kingdom that makes
them sound like Barry White.
Oh, yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, friends.
Trace here reporting on
the cute koala for DNews.
Nature sort of
determines how everyone
sounds based on their size.
Koalas are small, so you'd
think they'd make high-pitched
noises, but they don't.
Vocal cords are folds
of tissue stretched
across the inside of the larynx.
These folds determine how
I sound to you right now.
Generally speaking,
smaller animals normally
have smaller folds, and thus
make higher-pitched sounds.
It would be weird to see a
small dog with a deep bark
because their vocal
cords shouldn't allow it.
Koalas break the mold.
And until recently, we didn't
know how they were doing it.
Koalas are arboreal,
herbivorous marsupials.
They are not tiny bears.
They weigh as much
as 20 pounds, which
would make you think
that they sound
like that little cute
Kristin Chenoweth.
But instead, they
sound like Barry White.
Scientists from the
University of Sussex in the UK
found that, unlike
any other land animal,
koalas have a second set of
vocal folds outside the larynx.
National Geographic
says that they've
got the vocal depth
of something more akin
to an elephant
considering their size.
Oh, baby.
These folds are
at the point where
the oral and nasal cavities
meet called the pharynx.
When the koala inhales and
exhales through the pharynx,
it sounds like it's
repeatedly snoring
and then belching, which
might not sound sexy
to you, but for a lady
koala, bow chicka wow wow.
Now, their mates like it.
And in fact, the deeper snorey,
burping sounds they can make,
the hotter the ladies think
that their speaking is.
The lowest it would
seem that they can get
is about 9.8 Hertz, which is
lower than we can even hear.
These deep voices
might determine
whether the koala can
pass on its genes.
There's not a lot of energy
in eucalyptus leaves,
so they can't
exactly fight it out.
Instead, they sort
of koala purr,
attract their mates
more passively.
Fun fact.
Koalas are kind of dirty.
Chlamydia, pretty
common in their species.
Ew.
Since we're talking about
cute, fuzzy animals,
our friends over at
the Animalist Network
have a new show that you
might want to check out.
It's called Cat Mojo
with Jackson Galaxy.
All right, people.
Are you ready for some cat mojo?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I started working with
cats almost 20 years ago,
it was this very pure place.
But back to koalas.
If you could have a deeper
voice, would you want one?
Tell us in the comments
below and subscribe to DNews.
And you know what?
Why not share this video too?
It only takes a second.
Thanks for watching, everybody.
See you later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]